okay so it wasn't just kamala harris who
had a great interview this weekend which
which we looked at already
joe biden did an event in delaware about
rebuilding the american economy about
rebuilding the country really once
donald trump is gone
and uh so uh first of all
there are trump people who say biden
won't leave the basement as they like to
say
biden did an event he's not scared to
speak he spoke
perfectly fine seemed far sharper than
donald trump
biden also took media questions again
the trump people say biden won't do it
biden would crumble under questioning
biden doesn't know where he is
he can't put together a sentence didn't
go that way
and joe biden was asked about that trump
conspiracy group
i'm not even going to name it because
youtube instantly demonetizes
if you mention that group youtube
instantly demonetizes it but
let me put it this way it's related to
the letter that comes after
p in the alphabet let's just leave it
there if i'm sure you know what i mean
and biden is asked about that and biden
just destroys it
and goes very hard and says people need
mental health services now
biden is right about that this is a
crazy group
with outrageous beliefs or claims but
some of the people that
subscribe to those views might get
elected in november
as alex kaplan from media matters told
us last week
which is disturbing to recognize check
out joe biden's response
of the q anon the people who believe in
that conspiracy
what they think is true about america
that there's
sex trafficking and conspiracy against
the
president trump and what would you say
to president trump for
not rejecting that conspiracy
and the people who believe in it
i've been a big supporter of mental
health
i'd recommend the people who believe it
maybe should take advantage while it
still exists
in the affordable care act it's bizarre
totally bizarre and now
have you guys found that plain load of
people in uniforms and weapons and
flying around i mean you know
have you found them yet is anybody even
from
by the way i respect conservative and
liberal points of view in the press
anybody found that plane what in god's
name are we doing
look at how it makes us look around the
world
it's mortified it's embarrassing and
it's dangerous
it's dangerous
if the president doesn't know better
which i he has to
know better and my lord we're in much
more trouble than i ever thought we were
it's bizarre what in god's name are we
doing
is sort of in my mind the slogan for the
last four years it's a relevant phrase
not just when it comes to this group
but it's a relevant phrase big picture
for the administration joe biden
very clearly saying what many of us what
many in my audience have been thinking
which is
how does the entire country not realize
what the world realizes
which is that we are a laughingstock
with donald trump in the white house we
have become a joke
joe biden's saying it and then joe biden
again
showing more energy this weekend than
we've seen from him in a while
because he was very fired up about the
story
that donald trump said troops who died
in combat are
losers and suckers biden
visibly furious and disgusted with
donald trump this is a couple minutes
almost but i want to show you the entire
answer quite frankly
if what is written in the atlantic is
true it's disgusting
and it affirms what most of us believe
to be true
that donald trump is not fit to do the
job of president be the
commander-in-chief
the president reportedly said and i
emphasize reportedly said
that those who sign up to serve instead
of doing something more lucrative
are suckers let me be real clear
when my son was an assistant u.s
attorney and he volunteered to go to
kosovo
while the war was going on as a civilian
he wasn't a sucker my
son volunteered
and joined the united states military as
the attorney general
and went to iraq for a year won the
bronze star and other
commendations he wasn't a sucker
the service men and women he served with
particularly those did not come home
were not
losers if these statements are true
the president should humbly apologize
to every gold star mother and father
and every blue star family that he's
denigrated and sold it
who the heck does he think he is if it's
true
and based on other things he said i
believe the article is true
i'd ask you all the rhetorical question
how do you feel
how would you feel if you had a kid in
afghanistan
right now how would you feel
if you lost a son daughter husband wife
this was also really instructive to
from the standpoint of what i call dds
democratic derangement syndrome you
simultaneously had republicans
criticizing that answer
for diametrically opposed reasons you
had some republicans saying
oh my goodness joe biden's unhinged
he's going crazy about fake news
and then you had other republicans who
because the story has been quadruply
corroborated believe the story
saying what's wrong with biden biden
should have been more mad it almost
seems like he was
a low energy he could barely
even really get that that's weird why
wasn't biden more furious
about the comment if he believes that
he's does he not support the troops
so if you take every side of an issue as
donald trump and trump as typically do
you've got this sort of something for
everybody framing
which i've mentioned for some time uh
remember
joe biden said right before super
tuesday
we have to beat trump and the
republicans
but we can't become like them and i
think that
in our criticism of donald trump about
this suckers and losers thing
in our continued exploration of donald
trump's
you know denial of strokes that nobody
actually accused him of having
in all of this we have to make sure that
we don't become like them i tend to
agree with joe biden i want to win
but if we win the way they win have we
really won
and i've talked about this before and i
think it's something to keep in mind
especially as we get closer to the
debates which i'll be talking about next
just imagine if we see a fired up joe
biden at the debates
i don't think it will come off as
unhinged i think it will come off as
genuine and it will actually reflect the
feelings of many in this country
including some of us
who know that when every week is a
scandal
you start to become a little
desensitized so i was glad to see this i
think we're going to see more of it
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show
while you're there follow me on
instagram david.pakman you can see some
of my recent prepping
elements that i've purchased quick break
back after this
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman